حول هذا التطور ينضم الينا الان من جنوب
لبنان مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي وايضا
من الجليل الاعلى مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود لعلي ابدا معك حسان وما ترقبه اذا
في
السماء نعم سفيان رشقه واسعه من الصواريخ
اكثر من 20 صاروخا بالتحديد انطلقت من
جنوب لبنان باتجاه الجليل الاعلى والجولان
السوري المحتل ونحن الان هنا في الجليل
الاعلى نستطيع مشاهده بعضا من اثار
الحرائق التي تسببت بها هذه الصواريخ رشقه
واسعه انطلقت الى سماء هذه المنطقه وتلاها
اعتراضات من القبه الحديديه في المنطقه
حتى اللحظه لا نستطيع ان نحدد ما اذا كان
هذا الحريق الكبير الذي نشاهده في هذه
اللحظات هنا في في بالقرب من مجدل شمس في
الجولان السوري المحتل ما اذا كان ناجما
عن سقوط الصاروخ بشكل مباشر او ما اذا كان
ناجما عن شضايا الاعتراض من قبل القبه
الحديديه لصاروخ اطلق من لبنان هذه الرشق
كانت مكثفه انطلقت في سماء منطقه الجليل
الاعلى بالكامل وذلك بعد لحظات من دوي
صفرات الانذار و تلتها اعتراضات واسعه من
قبل القبه الحديديه لهذه الصواريخ في سماء
المنطقه هذا هذه الرشق تاتي ايضا في اطار
تصعيد واضح على طول هذه الجبه الممتده مع
جنوب لبنان وهي المره الثانيه التي تطلق
فيها رشقه مماثله اكثر من 20 صاروخا خلال
اليومين هذا اليوم واليوم الفائت بعدما
كانت ايضا المنطقه قد تعرضت وفقا لما اكد
الجيش الاسرائيلي لرشق ب 30 صاروخا باتجاه
منطقه الجليل الاعلى وتحديدا مقاب القطاع
الاوسط لكن اليوم مقابل اصبع الجليل
تحديدا انطلقت هذه الصواريخ في في محيط
وفي الحدود مع القطاع الشرقي في لبنان هذه
الرشق الصاروخيه الكبيره ايضا تاتي بعدما
كانت عده مواقع قد تعرضت لضربات بصواريخ
موجهه خلال اليوم باتجاه عدد من المواقع
الاسرائيليه كنا قد رصدنا انطلاق صاروخ
موجه نحو المواقع العسكريه الواقعه في
جبال مزارع شبعه حيث رصدنا الدخان المنبعث
عن هذا الصاروخ الذي اصاب تلك المنطقه قبل
ان يعود الجيش الاسرائيلي ويؤكد ان صاروخا
موجها انطلق نحو تلك المنطقه ولم يؤدي الى
اصابات وفق بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي الا ان
هذه الضربه ايضا هي من بين ضربات ايضا
تحدث عنها بيان للجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل
عندما اشار الى ان مواقع عده وبلدات عده
تعرضت لرشق صاروخيه من بينها مزارع شبعه
ال مطلي
وكذلك منطقه كريات شموه خلال هذه الرشقات
الصاروخيه التي وجهت من لبنان قال ان جميع
هذه الصواريخ سقطت في مناطقه غير ماهوله
وان الجيش رد بالمدفعيه على مصادر النيران
نحن نستطيع ان نؤكد ان الجبهه هذه الجبهه
الشماليه مع لبنان تشهد تصعيدا واضحا خلال
الايام الاخيره في كل المقاييس سواء كنا
نتحدث عن حجم الضربات الصاروخيه الموجهه
الى هذه المنطقه عن المواقع التي يتم
استهدافها عن طبيعه وانواع الصواريخ التي
ايضا يجري استخدامها وكذلك ايضا عن اتساع
الجبهه التي تصل اليها الصواريخ وعن
الكثافه التي تطلق فيها الصواريخ هذا ياتي
بعدما كنا قد تابعنا خلال يوم امس عمليه
اغتيال كما جاء في بيان للجيش الاسرائيلي
لقيادي في حزب الله يوم امس في النبطيه في
جنوب لبنان وكذلك ياتي بعد سلسله من
العمليات التي نفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي
والضربات لما قال انها مواقع وبنيه تحتيه
ل حزب الله في جنوب لبنان تحدث اليوم كذلك
عن استهدافات لعدد من المواقع في في جنوب
لبنان في الخيام
وا وفي كفركلا وا ايضا في طير حرفى خلال
هذه العمليات ايضا التي نفذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انه استهدف مواقع كان ينشط
بها الجيش الاسرائيلي او كان ينشط بها
عفوا حزب الله خلال هذا اليوم واطلقت منه
صواريخ هذا ايضا ياتي بعدما كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد اطلق عده ضربات مدفعيه
اليوم باتجاه عدد من البلدات ال اللبنانيه
في جنوب لبنان على امتداد الحدود ال
اللبنانيه مع منطقه الجليل الاعلى بشكل
رئيسي وكنا نلاحظ ايضا ايضا تكثيفا لتحليق
الطائرات الحربيه في سماء المنطقه وكذلك
تكثيفا ل الطائرات المسيره وطائرات
الاستطلاع في المنطقه ما زلنا نرقب ونشاهد
هذا الدخان ال المنتشر بشكل واسع في
المنطقه في الجليل الاعلى نتيجه للحرائق
التي تشكلت بعد هذه الرش المكثفه من
الصواريخ باتجاه هذه المنطقه ابقى معنا
حسان اذهب الى هياب العقدي في جنوب لبنان
اذا دفعه كبيره من الصواريخ تنطلق من
الجنوب في اطار هذا التصعيد بين الجانبين
اذا اللبناني وال الاسرائيلي ماذا في
تفاصيلها وهل معروف ما يراد
منها حتى الان على المستوى العسكري لا
يمكن التكهن بالهدف الذي كان يريده مطلقو
هذه الصواريخ ان كان حزب الله او غيره
باتجاه هذه المواقع حزب الله يتعمد في كل
مره اطلاق صواريخ وتضليل القبه الحديديه
ومن ثم توجيه صواريخ محدده باتجاه اهداف
يريد ضربها بدقه حتى هذه اللحظه حزب الله
لم يتبنى عمليه الاطلاق لكن ما يمكن
تاكيده ان هذه الصواريخ انطلقت من القطاع
الشرقي واستهدفت عده مواقع في اماكن
مختلفه من اصبع الجليل ومن الجولان
الدفاعات الجويه الاسرائيليه انطلقت من
الجولان لكن هناك صواريخ اخرى عبرت باتجاه
مناطق اخرى من اصبع الجليل كما افاد عدد
من المسؤولين هنا في جنوب لبنان كل ذلك
ياتي بعد تصعيد اسرائيلي واضح هذا اليوم
باستخدام مكثف للمسيرات والطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه المس الطائرات الحربيه اغارت
هذا اليوم على اخراج بلده كفرت بنيت التي
تقع في شمال الليطاني وهي عمليا منطقه
خارج العمليات العسكريه التي اعتدنا عليها
خلال الفتره الماضيه ايضا مسيره استهدفت
بلده يحمر اقيف واطلقت صاروخين باتجاه
منزل بالامس كان هناك غاره بالمسيرات
الاسرائيليه على سي
فيها مجموعه تابعه لحزب الله اطلق بعد حزب
الله اكثر من 30 صاروخا باتجاه قياده
اللواء المشاه الثالث في ما يعرفك زميم
هذه المنطقه التي تعد ايضا منطقه حيويه
بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيلي اعلن حزب الله
بان رده كان جاء بسبب هذه الاعتداءات
وزيادتها على مناطق مختلفه من جنوب لبنان
حزب الله اعلن مرارا بان عملياته قد تكون
عسكريه كما جرى هذا اليوم في سبع هجمات
اعلن عنها لكن بعض هذه الهجمات في السابق
كان يعلن في بياناته انها ردا على
اعتداءات اسرائيليه كانت تتجاوز الحدود
المتعارف عليها في العمليات العسكريه في
جنوب لبنان حزب الله هذا اليوم هاجم سبعه
مواقع اسرائيليه مختلفه هو اطلق صواريخ من
عيارات مختلفه على مواقع اسرائيليه في كفر
شوبه وركز الهجمات على منطقه تقع قباله
ميس الجبل وبليد وحبيب وعيون في القطاع
الاوسط وفي هذه الهجمات اطلق صواريخ واطلق
ايضا ما اسماه بالاسلحه المناسبه باتجاه
المواقع العسكريه الاسرائيليه وقال انه
تمكن من تدمير دبابه ميركافا اسرائيليه
فيما يعرف بموقع البغدادي طبعا كل ذلك جاء
وسط تصعيد اسرائيليا بالطائرات الحربيه
التي اغارت لليوم الثالث على بلده الخيام
مستهدفه منزلا وسط هذه البلده ودمرته بشكل
كامل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه غارت كذلك على بلده مارون
الراس ودمرت منزلا واصابت باضرار منازل
اخرى كما هاجمت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه
ثلاث مرات منطقه اللبونه بالاضافه الى
استهدافات اخرى بالمدفعيه الاسرائيليه
التي قصفت اماكن مختلفه في كفرشوبا التي
هجمت
مواقعها بالصواريخ كان هناك طائرات حربيه
هاجمت اطراف البلده وكان هناك قصف مدفعي
من الجانب الاسرائيلي لذلك فان هذا
التصعيد ياتي بعد ثلاثه ايام متتاليه من
التصعيد الاسرائيلي في جنوب لبنان وايضا
من استمرار حزب الله في الرد على الهجمات
الاسرائيليه واستمرار تنسيق عملياته على
ال المواقع الاسرائيليه المختلفه على طول
الحدود وهو يستخدم باستمرار اسلحه مختلفه
من صواريخ وصواريخ موجهه وايضا بالقذائف
التي التي يمكنها من خلالها تحقيق الاهداف
التي يريدها في المواقع الاسرائيليه وفي
الاهداف التي يقوم باستهدافها على طول
الجبهه التي تمتد على نحو 120 كت هو طول
الحدود او الخط الازرق الذي يفصل الحدود
بين لبنان وشمال اسرايل حزب الله كان اعلن
عده مرات بانه مستمر في مواجهه اي تصعيد
عسكري اسرائيلي وانه م مستعد لاي
سيناريوهات يمكن ان تقوم بها اسرائيل في
عملياتها على جنوب لبنان ابقى معي اعود
الى حسان مسعود اذا في الجليل الاعلى اذا
الجانب الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن توسيع رقعه
الحرب على هذه الجبهه هل من قراءات بهذا
الصدد اذا ما اضفنا احتماليه الرد
الاسرائيلي على هذه الدفعه الكبيره من
صواريخ وغير المسبوقه
حسان
نعم نعم سفيان الجانب الاسرائيلي عبر عدد
من مسؤوليه لا سيما مسؤول منطقه الشمال
قائد منطقه الشمال في الجيش الاسرائيلي
كما كذلك ايضا مسؤول وقائد القوات الجويه
في الجيش الاسرائيلي قام
ب قاما بالتصريح حول هذه الجبهه مؤكدين ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقوم بالاستعداد لاحتمال
توسيع الحرب على الجبهه الشماليه كان هناك
تصريحات لافته لا سما بعد الاغتيال الذي
جرى يوم امس في النبطيه عندما قام قائد
سلاح الجو بالتاكيد بان حزب الله سيواصل
دفع الثمن كما قال لهجماته المتواصله
باتجاه المناطق الاسرائيليه على طول
الجبهه وقال ان العشرات من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه تحلق في سماء جنوب
لبنان لكنها من الممكن ان تتحول الى مئات
الطائرات عندما تصدر الاوامر لتوسيع هذه
الجبهه فيما ايضا قائد المنطقه الشماليه
ينشط خلال هذه الايام في زياراته الى
المواقع العسكريه ومواقع التدريب في
المنطقه الشماليه لا سما هنا في الجليل
الاعلى ونحن من المهم ايضا ان نشير باننا
نسمع طيله اليوم ونرصد اماكن مغلقه تماما
وتشهد تدريبات متواصله للجيش الاسرائيلي
قائد المنطقه الشماليه يوم امس اكد ان هذه
التدريبات هي تدريبات للواء 188 والفرقه
36 التي تم سحبها من قطاع غزه وهي تقوم في
هذه المرحله بتنفيذ عمليات وتدريبات في
الجبهه الشماليه استعدادا لاحتمال توسيع
الحرب في الشمال وتحدث بذلك بشكل واضح
وقال ان ما يقوم به هؤلاء الجنود الذين
اتوا من غزه الى هنا الى الجبهه الشماليه
هو استخلاص العبر من التجربه في الحرب
والعمليه البريه في غزه والاستعداد لاي
حرب اخرى في عند الجبهه الشماليه ان اقتضى
الامر وفق قوله ايهاب في دقيقه يعني كما
تحدثت قبل قليل ان حزب الله يقول انه
مستمر في المواجهه مع اسرا ومستعد لاي
سيناريوهات هل هو نفس الاستعداد في على
المستوى السياسي في بيروت
ايضا ا بالنسبه
للبنان حزب الله يقول انه مستعد لاي توسعه
عسكريه من الجانب الاسرائيلي لكنه يعتبر
ان معركته هي معركه اسناد لقطاع غزه يقول
ايضا وهو ما جاء على لسان اكثر من مسؤول
فيه على مدى ايام كثيره ماضيه بان حزب
الله لم يستخدم في هذه المواجهات سوى 5%
من قدرته العسكريه لبنان الرسمي عمليا لا
يرغب بتوسعه دائره الحرب يرى بان وقف
اطلاق النار في غزه سينعكس حكما استقرارا
ليس على جبهه لبنان فحس بل على كل الجبهات
وصلت الفكره شكرا لك اذا اشكر ايهاب
العقدي وحسن مسعود